[Music]
google kubernetes engine turns
five yay happy birthday gke
but what is gk it is the first
cloud-based managed kubernetes service
and as we celebrate gke's fifth birthday
let's take a little journey through the
five things that we all love so much
about it
first off gke is easy to use
we all know that kubernetes is the de
facto standard for container
orchestration
but we also know that it can get complex
to operate and manage
that's where gke comes in it takes away
the complexity
out of kubernetes by providing a robust
command line
interface an easy to use ui to manage
all your containers in one place
it manages dns networking traffic
management
and load balancing amongst other things
and it works across
a lot of simple and complex use cases
including linux
windows stateful stateless existing or
new apps and single or multi-tier
cluster apps
second is trust
once you develop and deploy the app you
have complete control to manage that gke
environment
you get the choice to automatically
upgrade and repair them
if something goes wrong without worrying
about availability because google
site reliability engineers constantly
monitor your cluster
and its computing networking and storage
resources
with release channels you get the
freedom to choose the kubernetes version
of your choice you can choose the
cutting edge latest release
version in the rapid channel or choose
the most tested version in the stable
channel
or be in between in the regular channel
next is best price to performance
when you use gke you get the best value
for your money because it does
offer the lowest cost to performance
ratio for running the containerized
applications
it offers four-way industry-first auto
scaling to optimize resources
when you scale up and down your apps
based on your needs
for advanced apps you can use
application accelerators like gpus and
tpus on gke
and it helps kickstart your hybrid and
multi-cloud journey
next and very important is beyond prod
the cloud native security approach
with strong security defaults gke offers
cluster security beyond platform
hardening and os patching
the clusters in gke natively support
kubernetes network policy to restrict
traffic with pod level firewall rules
you can verify
and force and improve the security of
infrastructure components and packages
used for your container images
with the sandbox feature you get a
second layer of defense between
containerized workloads on gke
for enhanced workload security you also
get
built-in support for a wide range of
compliance standards
in short you get beyond fraud security
google's cloud native security approach
for your workloads
and we are on number five much needed to
navigate change
the only constant in our lives scale
whether you want to simplify your
infrastructure management
have batch processing needs or simply
looking to run
internet scale apps and absorb large
spikes in traffic
with gke you are in luck because
starting with 1.18
gke provides the most supported nodes of
any cloud-based kubernetes service and
three times the number of nodes
supported by open source kubernetes
how's that for five and five
are you ready to get started to
celebrate gke's fifth birthday we've got
something special for you
check out this link to learn more
[Music]